i i just guessed that
i had the hunch and i tried the
stuff and i found an example
yeah is your theorem uh for
distinguishing advantage like one or for
like any one that's epsilon
distinguishing
so you said that if you have a
distinguisher between plus and minus
states then you get some other circuits
uh if my distinguisher only has like one
path plus epsilon is languaging
advantage how how does that translate
into the resulting circuit
so i think remember exactly
so you you basically amplify this to one
and then you can turn it
actually you cannot actually there are
places where
you cannot define
okay so
[Music]
plans for locals
all right um yeah so um i'm millen i'm
a postdoc here at science institute and
math department in berkeley
and um
yes i'll talk about local hamiltonians
so it's it's a many body quantum system
with n qubits
so you have this exponentially large
state space
and m interactions
uh m could be a larger order than n
and so you know you can you can
draw the interactions as the hyperedges
on on this graph where the
vertices are
qubits
and so you each each interaction acts on
these
you know just a few of the cubes
we
will
demand that the uh the interactions only
act on a constant number
so that's the local hamiltonian the
local hamtonian is the sum of these
uh
individual interactions
and um you know this this is motivated
in many different ways you can see it as
a
quantum
constraint satisfaction problem or
and it can also represent feminic
systems
so now
i want to think of an approximation
setting
so
for approximation theory you
might want to rescale like this
so you divide by the number of
interactions
so with this rescaling the spectrum is
you know you guarantee that it's in
in the unit interval
but um even even so you know it's still
uh potentially hard to
approximate eigenvalues up to a small
constant error
you know so by the
classical pcp theorem that's np-hard to
approximate it up to some
small constant error
and it's conjectured that it's for local
hamiltonians even
harder so
conjecture to be qmi complete
now
okay so so that doesn't make the problem
easy but i want to introduce another
level of approximation
so instead of trying to resolve the
individual eigenvalues let me try to
um
get an idea of uh
what this what the spectrum looks like
sort of what the bulk of it looks like
so you know so we think of the
um
we take this spectral measure which is
just
you place the mass at each eigenvalue
and then you normalize it to be
a probability measure
right
so given the local hamiltonian can we
[Music]
can we get an idea of what this looks
like
okay so let me try to make an algorithm
for this and um
so
how might we how might we try to
approximate such a distribution well we
try to approximate the moments
right
and uh to get a small constant
um
error in the in the earth moving
distance
we only need a small constant number of
moments
okay
and now
thankfully we can
we can compute the piece moment for p
constant
because
this is the sum of the
the powers of the eigenvalues which is
the trace of the hamiltonian to the p
power
now because of locality we just um
we can
expand
the sum that
defines this h
so we get this
p fold sum
um now
you know each each of these uh small h's
here is local so when p is constant this
is also local so this we can compute
and uh so we we just end up with a time
that goes as the
end to the p terms here
so you know we can get an idea
of what the spectrum looks like in
polynomial time
um
okay so this seems nice
so unfortunately it it it won't give us
anything too
too useful
um and
so
what you'll find is that it just gives
you the information it gives you is sort
of universal too
and just follows from the from the
locality
um
and
and to see this let's try to do it by
hand
so
there's another so i drew like
a complete graph here to say that we
don't have to have
spatial locality or anything like that
so we might have a large degree
for example
so if we try to use the method from
before
to
to find the variance of
of the spectral distribution
but note that the the hamiltonian is
is deterministic so there's no
randomness here variance just means just
to quantify the spread
um
so we'll see that many of these terms
will end up being trivial so whenever
the two interactions don't um
don't overlap
uh you'll you'll get zero
and so
so so most of these terms will
end up being trivial and
um
you know more precisely
we can sum over the first i here and
then the second one
um
for each choice of i though they'll only
be supportive for the g choices of the
other one that overlaps which is the
degree
okay so in in the end
you know we get
we get that the second moment
goes to zero
and um
yeah so this is sort of a gaussian
concentration it looks like with
deviations of order one over square root
n
don't don't use any randomness here
so
so
this sort of gives us the concentration
in the horizontal direction but the
question is do we actually get
something that looks like an actual
gaussian concentration
so it turns out that you do
okay so
spectral measure will concentrate
exponentially
a similar result was shown recently also
by the palmer at all
but the proof here is very simple so
we can take the hamiltonian and split it
in to
make a coloring of the hypergraph
so we split it into matchings meaning
that
you know we split it into subgraphs
where in in each subgraph none of the uh
inductions overlap
and then for each color we apply the
turn off bounds so for each color this
this becomes uh a classical problem
where because the spec the spectral
distribution will just be a convolution
um
and then we'll use the fact that um
so to get uh you know the speed of
concentration will depend on the number
of
edges within that uh color within that
uh matching
and um
so so we lose something if we have many
colors
on the other hand we gain something if
we have many edges and these two effects
cancel out so in the end we get
a concentration that's exponential in n
now we might ask
you know could we have gotten even
better so exponentially an m
in the in the edges but uh that's not
the case because if we just look at a
single eigenvalue that'll
uh
its weight will be exponential just in
in
expansion decreasing
so this is the actual uh form that we
want
and then we can combine these using
eigenvalue inequalities
okay so uh
yeah so that gives a simple proof uh to
show some universal properties that of
the spectrum of a hamiltonian
that follows just from locality uh no
randomness all right thanks
[Applause]
thank you
any
uh could the questions be shown against
other distributions as well like this is
sort of a uniform distribution
i mean uh this theorem will be seen as
concentration of the energy
for uniform distribution on the
particular cubits
regenerating together institutions
um
so i'm not sure i understand this
question so uh do you mean
maybe you mean that the the interaction
strengths
are also uniform here i know so it's the
same journey
but you're looking at the
probability that a uniform distribution
the state's reinforced it could fall
under a certain energy vector
uh oh yeah yeah but you can ask for
other distributions as well anymore you
could ask the same question for
any room
and ask
what's the probability that that falls
in the
window oh yeah yeah
uh so for a different distribution
effect well yeah yeah so uh it doesn't
um
yeah it doesn't follow directly because
those
there's some issues applying that vows
uh
but uh yeah
um
so i'm not sure if you can do that yeah
well let's thank all the speakers for
this session
um
[Music]